we're pleased to have the indianapolis
colt deforest buckner uh formerly of the
san francisco 49ers right here on the
rich eisen show how are you sir
how you doing rich thank you for having
me again man thank you for coming on i
mean
what in the world is it like for you
right now i mean new team pandemic
you're about to get on the road
i'm assuming they're telling you what
the protocols are going to be getting on
a plane getting on a bus
going into a hotel i mean what is it
like for you right now
yeah um it's definitely a new norm uh
you know
uh changing you know going to a
different team and relocating is one
thing but having to deal with all the
the new things going on in the league
and uh how this year is going to go is
definitely different
something that you really got to adjust
to and um
you know like you were saying traveling
wise uh it's definitely going to be
different
obviously the organization's not going
to be able to travel you know
everyone that they want to that they
normally do um you know going to the
hotel
you know everybody's kind of you know
once you get there there's no leaving to
go dinner eat dinner or see family
uh you're you know you're stuck at the
hotel and um
i mean it's just it's gonna be it's
gonna be different for sure and then
going to
you know certain stadiums that there's
going to be absolutely no fans
that's definitely going to be different
you know with atmosphere-wise and
um having them you know pump crowd noise
and
and all that crazy stuff so it's
definitely different this year yeah i
mean so
if you wouldn't mind what what have you
been told about traveling are you going
to go on separate planes from some of
your teammates too to keep that
uh you know that's not something that uh
we went really went over yet
i'm pretty sure they're gonna go over
there go all over that pretty soon but
trout like well with the with the plane
and everything that's something i'm not
sure on yet
okay and but you have already been told
when you go to the hotel you're going to
your room and that's it
right you're you're shut down for the
night we'll have like you know i'm
sure we'll have meetings like we
normally do uh
they're gonna do a great job with making
sure everything's
you know six feet apart and things like
that like what they do here in the
facility but um as of leaving the hotel
and doing all that kind of you know
those things that you'd usually do on
the road going out to dinner as a unit
a little seeing family i mean that's you
know you're not doing any of that
if you're traveling with the team um
you're stuck in the hotel
deforest buckner here on the rich eisen
show that said everything
seems to be protocol wise set up in a
way where
um at least we feel comfortable talking
football
do you feel comfortable playing football
yeah um honestly i feel comfortable
playing football um you know
everybody wants to be out there playing
and every i feel like everybody's doing
a great job with
um being disciplined you know when we do
have free time on our off days you know
not being out and about exposing
yourself
because you know you expose yourself
you're not only hurting yourself you're
hurting your teammates
in the organization so um i feel like
the guys around the league are doing a
really good job because they want to be
out there
and so you know with that being said
being tested you know us being tested
every day
um you know gives me confidence that you
know i'm not exposed you know any
and not one person you know out there on
the field playing that everybody's been
testing negative so not any
no one's been exposed so i'm i'm
comfortable being out there fantastic
that's great to hear deforest buckner
here on the rich eisen show let's get to
you now
uh did you see the trade coming did you
sense it might be possible
oh walk me through that yeah for you
yeah yeah yeah um
yeah i did i knew i knew it was coming
um you know i
i knew actually a week kind of like a
week before the
they officially came out with it you
know that i was being traded to indy and
um uh yeah it was uh it was just a
business decision that was made and
uh you know it it's
it that's part of being in the league
you know what i mean uh you just gotta
adjust and
i'm just very grateful for a team to you
know invest in me and believe in me and
in my abilities and what i can bring to
the table yeah i mean did you at least
nod your head okay first round pick at
least they sent me first round pick you
know you worry first round pick
and years into your career you're still
that's your value
that's gotta did you at least nod your
head over something like that
oh yeah yeah and it's the little things
they gotta you know
you gotta appreciate and um you know
it's
i mean it just shows how much they you
know they they think of me
you know the cults and so uh you know i
i want to do everything in my power to
you know to reciprocate that okay so um
now when you take on jacksonville this
weekend at least you're going to be
hitting or going against somebody other
than your teammates that said
so far um what's your evaluation of
quentin nelson
being on the other side he's hands down
the best guard in the league
um you know quinn is uh he's a talented
player but he's also he's a technician
you know he works on this technique
every day
um you know we you know we talk about
certain things
um you know his hand placement or you
know how his feet were
you know and vice versa so um you know
he's he's looking to get better each and
every day and that's what i love about
him
you know he's not complacent he's not
content on where he's at in his career
he's only getting better and which is
crazy to say you know what i mean like
the
kid hasn't given up he's giving up what
one sec in two years
uh i mean he's a dominant uh run or run
blocker and
even more dominant uh pass protector so
um to be able to go against a guy like
that
each and every day will only help me get
better and you know
you know when i know practice is hard i
mean i know the game is going to be easy
so
yeah that being said i mean yeah he's
hands down the best guard
is he just as angry and ornery in
practice as we see in the game film is
that what you're saying
i know he you know a game days i think
he has a switch that he turns on
um you know he's he's a pro he knows how
to practice you know he's not out there
to hurt his own guys
um but but you know that being said
he'll also you know he practices hard
and then in terms of just you know uh
quarterbacks that you've you've been
around
as teammates philip rivers is um
you know i'm trying to go in my head if
you you and alex smith potentially ever
crossed paths but i mean um we're
talking about a guy
who has right now uh a totally different
new lease on life here and has
hall of fame credentials uh a ring a
ring would definitely
burnish that with possibly obviously a
window of opportunity for him closing
what what are you sensing from philip
deforest
yeah he's as good as they come um you
know philip is
you know he's a competitor you know if
i've ever seen one end
obviously a really smart intelligent
quarterback and um
i mean he's he's always been a guy that
i watched uh growing up i was a chargers
fan so
i was a philip rivers fan growing up uh
i mean i never told him this but
i was a big partners fan grew up growing
up and uh you know he
i mean he's as good as they come like
you said he's got all the hall of fame
credentials
um you know i mean now that he has a you
know
the best o-line in front of him in the
league um i
i can only you know imagine what he's
going to do this year
uh you know he was thrown for 4 000
yards last year
um i mean shoot i can see him throwing
for five
you know so it's it's going to be very
fun to watch him
you know moving forward this year so
you're saying like the 15 16 year old in
hawaii
uh was rooting for philip rivers that
that version of the farce box
yeah the chargers were my team growing
up go figure that now and now your
teammates for them it's it's amazing
um so i'm sure you're hearing the talk
about the jacksonville jaguars tanking
uh deforest you you see them first up um
what do you say to uh that conversation
that they are
tanking for trevor lawrence prior to a
season like this
yeah uh nobody in the nfl goes into a
season
thinking oh we're gonna tank the season
i mean we're gonna we're gonna come out
there obviously they know we're hearing
all this
all this you know stuff about their
tanking and all this kind of stuff
they're
traded they don't have a lot of talent
whatever so and so it's the nfl i mean
it's any given sunday and
we're gonna get their best and you know
we're gonna make sure that they get ours
so and it's a big division game um you
know we're
we're not going in there we're not
listening to the outside noise we're
going into preparing
you know to win and uh we got to play to
you know
towards the best of our abilities and
you know we got to bring it to them
and i'm sure you might be hearing this
as well deforest
um you know you're an oregon duck before
you were a professional football player
the fact that there's no human cry out
for pac-12
football not playing similar to a big
tent country
that you're living in right now yeah and
that maybe the pac-12 fan base isn't
nearly
as uh in love with football or
uh as rabbit about it as the big ten fan
what do you say when you hear that
yeah no i mean at the the the pac-12 is
a
you know everybody loves watching pac-12
games uh i gotta put a
i gotta i just gotta say that i mean uh
it's just unfortunate you know
the these two conferences are aren't
having games this year i was very
looking forward to
what the duck's going to do this year uh
with coach crystal ball and
i mean it's you know it's something that
we got to live with
i guess you know with the decision that
they they've made and
um it's just going to be weird not being
able to see my ducks play this year
all right last one for you deforest i
know uh the past is the past but uh
i do want to let you know that there may
be a coin toss uh with cleveland in your
future
uh once again but i i imagine in covert
you wouldn't be shaking hands with baker
mayfield anyway
no probably not okay so but you know i
don't know maybe you could figure out
some version of the dapping or anything
like that you know
i got you maybe i had not yeah head nod
just at least get that nod right i mean
at least
that's the body language that we'll be
looking at you know oh yeah
definitely all right take care of
yourself deforest okay
you be well be safe thank you appreciate
you calling in
thank you for having me again richard
you got absolutely that's deforest
buckner
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here